les institutions financières du canada
est de 44 pays gérant 130 mille
milliards de dollars de fonds font
alliance pour atteindre la
carboneutralité au total ces 450
entreprises qui forment une coalition
sous le leadership de mark cane l'envoyé
spécial de l'onu sur le climat et la
finance et la caisse de dépôt fait parti
de cette coalition son pdg charles mans
et à glasgow il est avec nous ce soir
bonsoir monsieur est mon
bonsoir monsieur clients qu'est ce que
ça change d'avoir la caisse de dépôt
puis plein des institutions financières
comme ça ensemble dans une coalition qui
participent à cette coalition
et je pense que ça lance un signal fort
à la communauté financière
vous aviez plusieurs joueurs qui doivent
jouer un rôle essentiel dans cette
transition là les gouvernements avec des
politiques claires qui stimule les bons
choix pour les consommateurs
légalement les entreprises qui doivent
incorporer la transition climatique dans
leur stratégie passé de conviction un
plan d'actions les investisseurs que je
pense ont pris un peu les devants depuis
quelques mois en démontrant qu'en
déployant capitale pour la transition de
l'économie
on peut faire bouger les choses et je
pense qu'il ya une convergence discret
et une opportunité d'alignement ces
trois joueurs loi est aujourd'hui bas
avec la coalition niveau des
institutions financières des joueurs
financier mais je pense qu'il ya une
consolidation de ses formes qu'il est
une sportive mais là on parle quand même
à glasgow en centres d'urgence et même
certains parlent de crise climatique qui
est en cours on reste sur un objectif de
carboneutralité en 2005 un salaire très
très loin 2050 est-ce que c'est pas un
objectif trop loin dans le temps
je suis d'accord avec vous c'est sûr
qu'on vise tout laquelle la
carboneutralité en 2005 à la caisse des
dépôts dans sa stratégie climatique ce
qu'on a toujours trouvé très important
c'est d'avoir des cibles ambitieuses
intermédiaire on a commencé en 2010 cet
axe nos stratégies climatiques pour des
objectifs en 2025 on est arrivé plus tôt
région a dépassé ses objectifs alors en
2021 on annoncé d'objectif pour 2022
prêts pour la sortie de la production de
pétrole 2025 pour les activer et 2030
pour réduire l'intensité carbone
donc c'est bien d'avoir 2050 mais au
delà de la vision et l'exécution et on
aime bien avoir des cibles intermédiaire
pour faire du progrès concrets mais ça
vous d'y aller par étape mais il y en a
pour qui et quand quand on écoute
attentivement les gens qui nous parlent
du réchauffement climatique qui est en
cours qui nous disent que ça va vraiment
pas assez vite qu'on va dépasser le 1 5
degré celsius de réchauffement assez
rapidement qui conserva à 2 puis même à
3 degrés celsius
vous avez raison il va avoir un besoin
de concrétiser cet engagement là de
carboneutre elle est tout prêt de
plusieurs joueurs de façon plus concrète
et de façon probable plus rapide
quand on regarde ce qui reste comme
marge de manoeuvre ce qu'on aimait ce
qu'on a réussi à effacer il ya encore un
effort important à faire et d'ailleurs
on dit souvent laquelle son portefeuille
80% les actifs qu'on a sur des actifs 01
ou à faible émission hockey et donc
malgré ce on aurait pu atteindre la
carboneutralité du portefeuille est ce
qu'on incite beaucoup aller vers la
décarbonation des grands émetteurs parce
que sinon passez à côté de l'objectif
important de créer la décarbonation
d'économie réelle est-ce que la coop 26
ou vous êtes présentement monsieur mots
vous amène à aller plus loin dans vos
réflexions puis vous allez revenir à
montréal avoue 10 à l'équipe on se
réunit on va encore plus loin
mais je vous dirai quand on a annoncé
notre nouvelle stratégie climatique avec
les quatre piliers en septembre on est
déjà ici je peux vous dire à
l'avant-garde de tous les investisseurs
de ce point de vue là ces quatre piliers
capellier qui sont stratégie qui sont
complémentaires on a reçu notre ambition
se décident existantes on en une
enveloppe de transition énergétique de
10 milliards on a sorti de la production
de pétrole en 2022 je rappelle c'est
pratiquement demain alors je vous dirais
qu'on se démarque déjà la coop 26 et en
ce sens la baisse et une stratégie qui
était ambitieuse mais qui doit être
pragmatique
lorsqu'on l'oubli 80 pour sa de l'offre
énergétique vient encore des énergies
fossiles le renouvelable on est un des
plus grands investisseurs d'avant
s'accroît vite le courage c'est encore
seulement 5% donc une transition devant
nous mais on va continuer à pousser cas
dépasser nos cibles s'est massé
francfort et non pas montréal qui va
avoir le siège social de ce qu'on
appelle les internationaux
sustainability stand-up the world
conseil la des normes de finance durable
est une déception pour vous parce que
vous avez mises avait milité pour
montréal pour que montréal est ce ce
bureau la
wii la quête se fait partie de l'effort
de vente à travers toutes les étapes
c'était un travail d'équipé avec
d'autres joueurs de l'écosystème
montréalais mais moi je le vois comme
une grande victoire cv il y avait
énormément de ville qui est en lice pour
obtenir
ce siège ceci âge là il ya francfort wii
via montréal il fallait s'attendre que
ce soit dans plus d'une ville parce que
je pense qu'ils veulent créer une
certaine concertation un espèce de
mobilisation plus large qu'avec une
seule localisation je pense que ça fait
de montréal impôts de l'investissement
durable dans les amériques et même dans
le monde moi je vois vraiment ça comme
une très belle victoire est quelque
chose qu'on se réjouit cette belle
nouvelle positive pour l'écosystème
montréalais québécois en finance durable
permettez une dernière question monsieur
et non sur air canada
la caisse de dépôt est un pilier de
l'économie du québec l'essor des
francophones dans l'histoire de
l'économie de montréal et du québec
passe beaucoup par l'essor de la caisse
de dépôt est ce que le pdg d'air canada
doit pouvoir parler et français et
anglais
d'un côté j'ai déjà commenté ce matin
elle la réponse du pdg d'air canada même
si ce n'est pas dans nos habitudes de
commenter spécifiquement les actions des
pdg je tenais réponse qui était
inacceptable et je le dis haut et fort
je pense que ça manque énormément de
sensibilité par rapport à l'écosystème
d'une entreprise qui base à montréal ou
6 par rapport à une clientèle bonne part
de sa clientèle qu'il francophone alors
on a vu des excuses de la part de
monsieur rousseau je pense qu'ils
s'engagent à maintenant améliorer son
français le reste bof suivent mais pour
nous la réponse le 7 a primé le plus tôt
ce matin hier était clairement pas
acceptable merci beaucoup monsieur
edmond d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i hier 10